لما العجله انها الاوامر
متاعب رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
تتناسل لا يسال عمران خان عن دواعي
الاصرار على معاوده اعتقاله لكنه يقول انه
يخشى اليوم من ان باكستان في طريقها الى
الدمار اذا لم يتم تغليف الحكمه
حصل زعيم اكبر حزب سياسي المعارض في
باكستان على تمديد فتره الافراج عنه
بكفاله من محكمه اسلام اباد العليا حتى
نهايه الشهر الجاري وما زال خان يطالب
اجراء تحقيق قضائي المستقل في اعمال الشغب
التي عقبت اعتقاله المؤقت مطلع الشهر على
ذمه واحده من عشرات القضايا التي تلاحقه
حزبه انصاف عبر عن قلقه البالغ مما سماها
هيمنه روايه حزب سياسي محدد على الاعلان
الصادر بعد اجتماع لجنه الامن القومي خلال
الاجتماع هدد رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
شهباز شريف بمحاكمه مرتكبي اعمال العنف
وقادتهم كارهابيين تتحدث السلطات
الباكستانيه عن اعمال شغب مميته تخللتها
مهاجمه منشات امنيه ومقر حكوميه وتنسيبها
الى انصار رئيس الوزراء السابق
تبرئ عمران خان نفسه من الفاعلين وطالب
بتحقيق النزيه كما نفع عن نفسه الاتهامات
بالكسب غير المشروع
ومع ذلك استدعته هيئه المحاسبه وزوجته
للمثول امامها الخميس في القضيه المعروفه
بارض جامعه القادر هي القضيه التي كان خان
قد اعتقل بسببها قبل عشره ايام لفتره
وجيزه الحقيقه ان عمران خان الذي اطيح به
في تصويت على الثقه بالبرلمان في ابريل
العام الماضي يواجه قضايا فساد عده انصاره
يرون في المساله برمتها فارا سياسيا من
الرجل الذي يقود حمله شعبيه ضد الحكومه
الحاليه والجيش واسع النفوذ اذ يتهمهما
بالتواطئ لاقالته من منصبه والتورط في
فساد هائل بل ويتوعد هؤلاء جميعا
بالمحاسبه اذا عاد الى الحكم تلك هي
المشكله للبلد شواغل اكبر يقول مراقبون
محايدون فلم المخاطره بتعميق حاله عدم
الاستقرار السياسي في باكستان التي بالفعل
اسوا ازمه اقتصاديه على الاطلاق انها من
الاحتمالات التي تقلق الباكستانيين
وجيرانهم وحلفائهم اما بالنسبه لنجم رياضه
الكريكت السابق فهذه مباراه نوع اخر فرضت
عليه ولا يبدو انها من النوع الذي ينتهي
بالاعتزال